we played the Packers this week and I
was talking to Aaron Rodgers on there
and I was asking I was like Hey like why
are y'all not passing the ball y'all
down 17 points why are you not passing
the ball and like I'm not gonna tell you
what he said because I don't you know
I'm not gonna use it no no no I'll tell
you what Aaron said I ain't got nobody
to throw it to I don't trust none of
them I wish I could throw it to myself
that way what he said to you I don't
trust these boys they couldn't catch a
cold in the snowstorm in Alaska like
that's what he said you guys then you
Aaron Rodgers you can get some guys open
and you can tell them little tricks like
hey right when I come up to play action
if you hit this slant I'm gonna hit you
right over the front like getting them
open ain't the problem he hitting them
why are they open they dropping the rock
yeah I seen that too all right he's
saying run post and they running Corner
are you saying run a stop they running a
go and then he looking crazy throwing
the ball and he's sitting there sick I
don't know what's going on